we are working around the clock to fight
the public health emergency posed by the
coven 19 outbreak to mitigate its impact
and treat those affected it has been an
all-out effort to beef up health
services help companies remain in
business and keep people in jobs and
provide for them through this period of
profound economic disruption we are
moving fast in only one week our fiscal
measures to support the economies of the
euro area have about doubled in size
these on top of all automatic
stabilizers which are very powerful in
our economic and social models the
European Commission has the facto
suspended the constraints of our fiscal
rules the European Central Bank is
taking exceptional action with a new
program to support financial stability
and prevent further fragmentation all
these is unprecedented and more is
coming institutions like the sm the
European Commission and also the IB are
exploring ways to increase our crisis
response firepower all these
institutional efforts are complementary
and coordinated our aim is to add new
lines of defense to the euro preventing
these economic crises to morph into a
financial one this is what will be at
the table of the Euro group today we
will be laying the ground my aim is to
report solutions to leader summit this
Thursday not curtailing any possible way
forward our capacity to look ahead is
key to achieve informed decisions at the
highest political body of our union